hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal
wieder eines meiner lieblings gerichte
beziehungsweise kategorien wir machen
reist wer mich kennt weiß ich liebe reis
reis gibt es bei mir fünf mal die woche
um gelogen und heute machen wir ganz
speziellen reist nämlich persischen reis
und zwar der mit der ta die kruste also
tat ich bedeutet eigentlich kruste und
viele sagen dann noch umgangssprachlich
zarte kreis und den gibt's heute das ist
somit kleine königsdisziplin aber ich
zeige euch wie ihr euch ganz einfach
gelingt und dafür zeige ich euch jetzt
zuallererst die zutaten
wir benötigen was martin langkornreis
außerdem salz butter geben neutrales öl
ich hab sonnenblumenöl verwendet und
ganz wichtig ist safran bevor wir jetzt
allerdings starten müssen wir den reis
einmal schön ausspülen unter fließendem
leitungswasser ich nehme dafür gerne
immer ein haar sieht und schaue dass die
ganze stärke heraus gespielt wird denn
das bewirkt dass unser reist später
richtig schön feinkörnig ist und nicht
klebt und er erkennt daran dass ihr
bereit seid wenn das wasser unten klar
wieder rauskommt und ich verwende heute
den reis hunger reiskocher und das hat
auch einen ganz bestimmten grund bei mir
alle alarmglocken aufgeleuchtet als ich
gehört habe dass da eine christi
funktion hat und ich sage jetzt auch
persönlich gerne tadic funktion dazu
denn der wird später einfach dass wir
eine richtig schöne goldbraune kruste
bekommen und jetzt werden wir den reis
aber zuallererst vorkochen und zwar gebe
ich dafür den reis hinein mit ungefähr
eineinhalb liter wasser so und dann
zeige ich euch wie ihr das vor kochte
das nämlich noch nicht ganz durch
[Musik]
so und das wasser darf wo ich vier bis
fünf zentimeter über dem reis stehen
wichtig ist dass wir das ganze jetzt
erstmal nur vor jahren also es darf
nicht ganz durch sein und ich gebe jetzt
noch salz dazu das ist ganz wichtig
damit es schon mal den geschmack annimmt
ich gebe jetzt ungefähr zweieinhalb
teelöffel rein und verrührt das noch mal
ganz kurz
so und jetzt schließen wir den deckel
und werden das ganze ca 12 minuten lang
auf der turbo funktion vorgaben so ihr
lieben nach circa zwölf minuten breche
ich den vorgang gibt es bewusst ab dh
der reißt er hat schon an volumen
deutlich zugenommen ist aber noch nicht
ganz da und das ist genau richtig so
jetzt gehe ich noch mal kurz ins
spülbecken und werde das unter
fließendem kalten wasser noch mal
abspielen das gleich
[Musik]
so mein reist gebe ich jetzt an die
seite denn wir machen jetzt weiter mit
unserem butter g und dem öl dafür gebe
ich jetzt erstmal in diesem topf einsatz
zurück in den reisekoffer und wir haben
ja noch recht hitze von unserem turbo
vorgang
deshalb werde ich jetzt butter geht
einfach direkt rein tun dann schmeckt
das ganz langsam vor sich hin
dann gebe ich noch dazu und dann zeige
ich euch wie es weitergeht
so während das gerade vor sich hin
schmerz erkläre ich euch doch mal ganz
kurz was butt ag ist viele fans auch
vielleicht als butter schmalz oder unter
dem namen geklärte butter denn das ist
reines butterfett hatten total eigenen
geschmack schmeckt meiner meinung nach
sowohl bei herzhaften gerichten als auch
bei süßen herbst schon in meinen
orientalischen rezept videos gesehen und
wir gehen jetzt über zum sachfragen auch
ein sehr edles orientalisches gewürzt
und das hat einfach ein total eigenen
geschmack und gebt dem reise noch mal
eine richtig schöne geschmackliche als
auch eine schöne farbliche note den gebe
ich jetzt einmal in den mörser und mache
ich dann ein bisschen klein dann zeige
ich euch wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
und schaut mal wie schön goldgelb das
schon aussieht freue ich mich schon
richtig auf patrick macht er auf dieses
schöne kruste und ich gebe jetzt noch
zwei messbecher warmes wasser da hinein
und verrührt es dann miteinander
[Musik]
und die hälfte von unserm safran
gemischt geben wir jetzt in den topf
butter und öl sind auch gut miteinander
verschmolzen die hälfte einmal da
reingeben die andere hälfte brauchen wir
gleich noch so ihr lieben wir gehen
jetzt unser als komplett in den topf und
durch das erste vorgaben hat es schon
ganz gut salz aufgenommen ihr könnte
dabei an der stelle noch mal nach seiten
ist aber in meinem fall jetzt nicht
nötig
so der reise ist drin jetzt kommt der
rest von safran wasser hinein einfach
drüber geben und dann alles schön an der
oberfläche glatt streichen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der teil auf denen ich
mich schon die ganze zeit freue
wir werden jetzt die christie funktion
aktiviert einfach dem decke runter geben
und dann gebe ich hier in das menü geht
einmal auf christi und dann einfach
einschalten der rest erledigt wirklich
der reiskocher eineinhalb stunden dauert
das ganze ist dann habt ihr schon eine
richtig schöne goldbraune kruste nach 60
minuten ist die nicht ganz so goldbraun
dann müsste einfach mal selber schon wie
ihr das am liebsten möglich und ich bin
gespannt ich zeige euch welche cent
ergeben ist so ihr lieben die vorfreude
steigt 90 minuten sind um
und hier sehe ich eine zahl von neun
minuten das heißt seit neun minuten ist
der reiskocher jetzt im warmhalten modus
das heißt auch wenn ihr mal wissen was
zu tun habt und nebenbei noch falsch
oder so was zubereitet dann hält er den
reis schön warm jetzt einfach öffnen und
dann den topf draußen schön an den
seiten damit ihr euch auch nicht
verbrennt und jetzt stützen wir das auf
einen ausreichend großen teller
und fertig ist unser köstlicher
persischer reis mit der leckeren tat ich
mit dieser kruste und ich freue mich
wenn ihr es ganz natürlich nach macht
und mir eure fotos zusendet aber kurz
vorher noch den hinweis auf die genauen
mengenangaben hier unten in der infobox
findet und natürlich auch die links zu
den passenden produkten ihr bekommt
safran tim rice hunger shop außerdem
natürlich auch den reiskocher butter
gereist alles was ihr für dieses rezept
benötigt ich freue mich außerdem wenn
ihr mir in den kommentaren schreibt ob
ihr noch andere varianten vom ta die
krähen möchte zum beispiel gibt es auch
die kartoffelkiste oder die mit dem brot
schreibt es mir gerne mal ich bin immer
offen für neues und ich freue mich dass
ich dieses rezept endlich mal
ausprobiert habe denn leute ich habe
immer nur gelesen dass sich die leute um
diese kruste streiten ich verstehe
absolut warum das ist so lecker ihr habt
auch für diese goldbraune kruste und
innendrin feinkörnigen reist mit dem
leckeren safran und buttergeschmack also
macht unbedingt nach ich bin total
gespannt auf euer feedback und freue
mich wenn ihr beim nächsten mal auch
wieder dabei seiten guten preis sondern
alle tschüss
[Musik]